I'll tell you a great story about him  and running and how huge this victory  was so when we finished up my book tour  the last stop that we did was in Orlando  and I had DeSantis as my special guest  so we went right into Disney and and did  this show there and they had protesters  and they're screaming and all the usual  nonsense but I'm sitting in the green  room with the governor Just the Two of  Us for about 10 minutes before the show  and we're just mostly want to talk about  baseball actually we're just kind of  yeah like it wasn't about politics he's  just a decent dude and uh and I said to  him I said uh you know Governor you're  going to win this thing by 15 points he  laughed in my face he said six or seven  six or seven and now he won by 20. I  mean think about that he thought six or  seven he said six or seven and that  would be huge and the guy won by 20